hey everyone persia here and welcome to
the game pass show where
we're gonna tell you what's in what's
out and
what needs a little more clout when it
comes to all
things game paths so leave a like
subscribe
and let's get started
as far as new games what is coming to
game pass are as follows we've got
worms rumble
iron harvest
[Music]
need for speed hot pursuit remastered
proteus
bug fables the everlasting sapling
game beast which we played on play for
all recently
immortal realms vampire wars and one of
my personal favorites
limbo so if you want to play limbo and
you've never played it before
that is coming soon so be sure to check
it out now the sad news of what is
leaving game pass battle chasers night
war
marvel vs capcom infinite goodbye dear
friend
missed over monster hunter world out of
the park baseball 21
outer wilds another personal favorite be
sure to play that before it's gone
soul calibur six and the messenger
now when it comes to game pass there are
a ton of games and sometimes it can
be a little daunting trying to figure
out where to start so
that's why our next few segments are
featuring some games that we're playing
and our pick of the week so for me i
have been playing
sea of thieves the new pirates of the
caribbean
dlc crossover action is now
on game pass one of my favorite things
so far
about the sea of thieves and pirates of
the caribbean
crossover is that when you jump in with
friends to these tales it's like a giant
puzzle that you can solve together
and there's already been moments in the
beginning of these tales where we did a
few things
out of order and we actually missed a
moment that we could have unlocked
because we progressed too far along and
now we actually have to go back and do
them again did that do anything or
yeah oh he's gonna talk now one of my
personal favorite things about sea of
thieves is that i
can have a doggo so running through the
campaign
with my friends seeing jack sparrow i
got my dog by my side
it's been really really fun and a nice
breath of fresh air into sea of thieves
oh my gosh i recently started playing
this game because
of game pass and kind of wanted to see
more out of it so when we got these
crossover announcements during e3 it was
super exciting me and my friends were
super stoked and now we've been jumping
in but we haven't finished yet
thankfully it is all on game pass so
that we can all link up and play
when we can all link a biblio to be
honest i love
co-op games but getting the whole squad
on at the same time
is a little bit more of the hard part
but thankfully
it is on game pass and it's ready
whenever we are
all right now it's time for our pick of
the week and honestly going into this
i had a different pick to start but
looking at the games leaving game pass
this month
it was an easy pick the pick of the week
is outer wilds if you have not played
this game
please give it a shot if you have game
pass on console or the cloud
get this game and play it before it's
gone you have
less than a week but definitely worth
checking out if you haven't so far
one of my favorite games of all time i'm
praying and hoping we see
a second one in the future or something
but regardless
play it while you can because it's going
to be gone soon
alright everyone that is the game pass
show
make sure you get your hands on these
games or keep an eye out for the new
ones as they arrive
and make sure you tune in here again in
just a few weeks for your next update
thank you so much and we will see you
next time peace
you